Osinga: Hello, everyone.
Hi.
[laughs]
Um...whoa.
This is a little loud.
Welcome to the API talk,
the talk where we explain
how you can program
for and with Wave,
how you can build applications
that interact with Wave.
Before I get started,
I'd like to remind you
that you can put feedback
on this presentation
on www.haveasec.com/io.
And we'd really appreciate that
if you do that.
So, um...
yeah, let's get started.
There we go.
So yeah.
As I cannot stress enough,
this is a developer preview.
We'll start giving out accounts
on wavesandbox.com, um...
anywhere from now
and next week or so.
You're all invited to explore
Google Docs
with the API descriptions
on them.
They should be live already.
Also we have a blog site
that gives you more information.
And you'll get an email
at some point
with instructions
as to how to sign into
this wavesandbox.com domain
where you'll find the client
that you saw in the
demonstration this morning,
and that should allow you to...
interact with using, you know,
building robots
and extensions and all
that sort of goodness.
Yeah.
So...Wave building.
This is...
the Wave Building in Australia.
I, um, I'm personally
always a fan of building slides
that have mostly
a picture in them,
and then I tell the story
about it.
But I was told that
I couldn't do that
for this presentation
since people would be looking
at the presentation afterwards.
This is sort of like the only
reminder that they have.
It's fitting because,
you know,
we're talking about how you can
build stuff on top of Wave,
and our team
is based in Australia.
So I thought
I'd slip it in anyway.
So before you get--
do a dive into
the various APIs that we have,
I thought it might be
a good idea to take a moment
and look at what a Wave is
from an architectural
perspective,
other than the pretty pictures
that Lars showed you
this morning.
So a Wave is actually...
not much.
It's an envelope
that has wavelets in them
for the physicist under you,
that might be--
physics students under you,
that might be
a little confusing,
because wavelets
are already used
for something else there too.
Hey, what can I say?
So essentially,
a wavelet is a complete Wave
and has participants on them.
And the reason that we split
waves up in wavelets
is to manage permissions.
So each wavelet--
each wavelet
has the same permissions,
and the permissions are usually
assigned to the participants.
So in this case,
we have one Wave...
with the top thing
has five participants
and, you know, there's some sort
of discussion going on there
about what to get for
food this evening.
And then you can see
the second wavelet,
which has a subset
of the participant
of the first ones on it.
And there you see that,
you know,
these two guys think that,
actually...
you know, let's not get pizza,
have to get Mexican food.
So to the clients, this will
look like a private reply,
as you might remember
from the demo this morning.
Now, we have two types
of APIs and, um,
the first one is embedding.
The second one is extensions.
I like to say that,
you know, with embedding,
you can take Wave
and put it out in the world.
And with extensions,
you can take bits of the world
and put it in Wave.
So the embedding API is...
is much inspired
on the Google Maps API
and lets you take a Wave
that you have
and display it
on your website.
This is a very simple schema
describing that.
So this is a, supposedly,
chess site
where we have a tiny bit
of script include,
which is the library
that we provide,
that you put on
your website.
You then tell this,
you know, what to do
and in reaction to that,
that piece of script
goes to ahead
and essentially, it's a complete
version of our client
minus all the chrome
around it.
And that thing lives
in an iframe
and communicates
with the Wave Server
so that you get
all the liveness
and all that sort of thing
for free.
I have to say that the API
that we're going
live with right now
is fairly restricted.
We're still working on this,
and over the coming
weeks or months,
we hope that we can expand it
and to make
a lot more possible.
So right now
you can load a Wave.
You can set
the UI configuration
of, you know, how you
want to display that Wave.
You can add a reply,
and you can follow.
Now, these last two things
need a little explanation,
because actually,
what they do
is they let the page
that you embed the Wave on
request the Wave client
that sits in that page
to add the current user
to that Wave
so that the current user
follows that Wave
or requests the current user
to create a reply
inside of that Wave.
So this way you can,
as a developer,
you put a little button on there
saying reply.
And what happens, in fact,
is that the person that is
logged into the Wave client
replies by clicking that.
So here's a bit
of a example code...
of how that works in...
practice.
So we start by having--
Oh! I did not know
that would happen.
So here on the top--
I wish I had a pointer.
We have pointers?
No pointers.
And I can't select it,
because then I go
to the next slide.
So here on the top,
we have a waveframe
that is just a div
saying like it's 500 pixels
width--500 pixels high,
and it's, you know,
the entire width of the page.
We include
the bit of JavaScript here
from this bit of temporary URL
that we're currently using.
We're working on getting
something better,
but in the haste
to get to this event,
it took us a little while
to get there.
So...and then we go ahead
and we create a Wave panel.
We request this Wave panel
to be hosted
on the Wave Sandbox thing
as we...you know,
once we get to the point
where we have a public launch,
we'd no longer
have to specify that,
because then it would
just be the global thing.
But right now it's only for
the developer preview,
so you only get that bit.
And here we get the hairy bit
of the API, load Wave,
and you do that by specifying
a Wave ID.
There's ways around
to get the right Wave ID.
I'll get to that.
And now we go ahead and we
fill the Wave panel to init
and to put its work
on this URL here.
So...in practice,
that looks like this thing here,
which is the same source code
as I just showed.
And if I double-click
that thing,
it will go ahead...
with a little luck
load a Wave.
So this is a Wave
that is live on the thing,
and it looks just like
a normal web page,
but if I hover over it,
I can just, you know,
go ahead and I can actually
reply to this thing.
So that's as simple as...
as that...as embedding is.
Now we have...added--
like I said,
there's a few more things
that you can do with embedding.
Um...
Here I added a button
to leave a comment,
and I decided not to go with
the default styling
but choose for
a black background
and red lettering
and courier new
to give it a nice
aggressive look.
'Cause, you know,
that's always good
for this sort of
pubic demonstrations.
So if you load that one,
you get...
Tch. Ta-da.
So it's the same--
it's the same blog.
And I can, you know,
I have--
you can see this
in the Wave client too.
You can see that the reply
that I just made
is here and here's
the add comment button
that would do
essentially the same thing
as, uh, as before.
Going back
to the presentation.
So that is the--
this is where we are
with embedding.
Ooh, yeah.
We have a little preview,
developer stuff inside
of Google, of course, too,
and somebody came up with
this really nifty application
of embedding
where he, uh, has taken
a normal gadget
and put the embedding code
inside of the Google Gadget.
So now you have this thing
that allows you
to take a Google Wave
and put it on any website
that supports gadgets
in a very simple way.
And this also has the advantage
that, you know,
he came up with a whole bunch
of user preferences
that lets you configure
the way that the Wave
looks in your thing.
So instead of having to do
all the JavaScript yourself,
you can just, you know
go ahead, insert the gadget,
and now you get this
nice little diagram
and, you know,
you click submit,
and you get this Wave
on your iGoogle page.
So if you would, you know,
have your team meeting notes
in Google Wave
but you normally use
iGoogle to start your day
then you could, you know,
put that Wave in iGoogle
and type directly there
to Wave or, you know,
go to the Wave
client from there.
In the demo you saw, um,
how we used the embedding API
to extend Orkut.
I hope I don't disappoint you
too much that, uh,
we're not quite ready
to release that bit of the API
that makes that possible.
There are some security things
there that keep us from that.
But we have a ambition
to make it completely possible
to...essentially
build your own--
assemble your own Wave client
using the embedding API
and to go as far as
make it possible to embed waves
that let your users
communicate with each other
using Wave with their own
sort of database of waves
without requiring your users
to log into Google,
which is one of the things
that we currently do.
So that we'll make it possible
to just take Wave
and use it
for your applications,
and, you know,
people will never have to
first sign up
for whatever service we have.
Okay...
That brings us
to the bigger part of our API,
extensions.
So extensions are
the things that, uh,
let you, as a developer,
extend Wave.
Currently, we have two
types of extensions.
We have robot and gadgets,
and, um, the distinction is...
really that a robot
runs on a server
and a gadget runs
on a client.
It still often gets
confusing,
so hence this little
explanation here.
So a robot runs in the server,
runs in the cloud,
and talks to our Wave Server
directly.
And so it communicates
by the user, with the user
by manipulating the Wave,
and then the user
can manipulate the Wave back,
and that way,
they communicate.
While a gadget is just a normal
open social type of gadget
that gets extentiated
inside of our client
and that can talk
directly to the user
because it has
a bit of the screen.
And it can store its state
in the Wave,
so if you have a gadget
that is on a Wave
that is being viewed
by five people at the same time,
then those five people
each have their own instance
of this gadget.
So, let's talk a little bit
more about, um, gadgets.
So here's the...
the basic model...
of gadgets.
We have this page,
LS Wave client
which shows the user
what it is.
And it maintains
an XML document
that is the entire state
of that Wave.
And any time you do something
to do the Wave
using the Wave client,
it looks like
you're manipulating the HML.
But in the background we,
you know,
manipulate the XML documents.
And if you make a change,
then the client calculates
the change that you made
since this diff or op over
the wire to the Wave Server--
The Wave Server
applies that to the, you know,
to the actual
canonical version of the Wave...
takes into account of all
the changes of the other people
and then sends back
the operations
that bring the client
in sync
with the canonical version.
So that's, you know,
very briefly how our...
how our collaboration thing
works.
If you want the details,
we have a talk at 2:15,
I think, with a--
where we take
a much deeper dive
into, you know,
the technology behind this.
For gadgets, this is really
all you need to know.
So this gadget
sits in its iframe,
and it can do
whatever gadgets can do,
But we have this nice
little library
that lets the gadget
make modifications
to the XML document.
For now, it can only change
one note in this XML document,
and this is the--
well, its own gadget note
where, essentially,
all it gets to do is set
a bunch of key value pairs.
But you can pretty much
represent any state
in a list of key value pairs.
So that's all good.
Um...that API
that I was talking about
basically has three bits.
We have the Wave object.
The Wave object
gives you access
to the participants
on that Wave.
It also gets you,
you know,
gives you access
to the state object
that I was talking about
before.
Furthermore, we have
a thing called the mode.
So the Wave can be
in a whole bunch of modes.
The most important thing
is that
sometimes you want to
distinguish what happens to--
how you display things,
whether you are in playback mode
or whether you are
in edit mode.
And the same for--
although we don't support it
right now,
but...remember
during your demo,
if you go back to a Wave
that you have been,
you see the differences
that were made last time.
We want to support that
in gadgets too
so that you write a chess game
and you go back to a Wave
that has this chess game on it.
You can show the user
what happened
since last time he looked.
So you can sort of show
all the arrows
of all the pieces that moved.
We think that is a very
powerful thing to do.
So the state object
lets you submit deltas,
and it lets you
query the state.
And the way that work is
you always submit
deltas to the state,
and then you get called back
with this is the new state.
The reason that we do this
is that you're not the only one
modifying a state.
So that way we guarantee
that any time you get
called back with the state
that it's actually the state
and not something that
you think you would be creating.
Last thing that we have
is the participant object.
Participants
are anybody on the Wave,
including robots,
and we give you access for now
to the name of the participant
and to the thumbnail URL.
Well, let's have a look
at some actual code.
This is just a reminder.
Just for my sense,
how many people here
have, uh, taken the time
to write a gadget before?
Okay, well...
that's not too many.
So this is a bare bone gadget.
It's essentially
an XML document
within the middle, uh,
a bit of HTML here and...
it tells...
you send this
to the gadget server
and it configures a iframe
for you from a perspective.
And so if you would load
this gadget
inside of a iGoogle
or whatever,
you would just see
Hello Wave--this thing here.
'Cause that's really
all it does.
So that's not very interesting.
And I'm not going even
to show you this,
because it's not much
of a demo.
One thing I learned from Lars
is that, you know,
if you want to make a nice demo,
throw in a map.
[laughter]
So...
That's what I did here.
It's the same gadget as before.
But now what we do is,
you know,
easy, easy Maps API.
We create a map here,
set it on 3,500, 35,
which is, you know, Japan.
I--wrong number but so...
now we can go to the Wave client
and uh--ooh.
We can go to the Wave client...
and we can open that map.
It's here.
And with a little luck,
it will even load.
Oh, come on!
Well, I guess it's better
for me that it doesn't load
than, you know,
this morning, but still...
Seems unfortunate.
Well, you know,
let's assume it loaded,
then it would look like this.
[laughter]
So the thing is that...
ah, there we go.
So the thing is this--
this is a nice, you know,
it's a map.
And you can move it around
and...you know.
It shows that you can
basically take any gadget
from the gadget galleries
that we have and...
drop it into Wave and it will,
you know, it will play.
So we have...you know...
The thing though, is,
that if I move this map around
and you're also looking
at this map,
then, you know,
you see your own version.
And if I...
so, you know, if I focus
this thing on like Europe
and then I go to a...
different Wave here...
oh, man, this is not good
that it loads so slowly.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: Huh?
[man repeats]
Osinga: I know, but I'm supposed
to be on a special wired network
that's much faster
than what you guys got.
[laughter]
Um...
Anyway, so the point is
I go back to this Wave,
and whoop--
now I'm back in Japan.
It doesn't save its state.
So we can use the...
the API...
to do exactly that.
So in the next slide,
what we did add here
is a little...so now
we're getting to the point
where, you know, unload.
What we do is we say, well,
you know, set...
take this set change--
interesting, it doesn't--
It's called
a state changed method
as soon as I--as soon as
the state of the gadget changed.
And we add a listener
to the map.
As soon as we're done with
the dragging of the map,
we submit a delta
saying that the key
latitude and the key longitude
are now set to the latitude
and longitude of the map.
And in the state changed,
we actually take the map
and move it go
those keys from the state.
The point here is that...
this will execute on
all clients at the same time.
So essentially
what we do here is
if any of the...
any user of any of those gadgets
moves that map around,
then all the gadgets
get the state changed.
So they will all, you know,
synchronize
the move of the thing.
And now, with a little
network luck,
I can show you this other
version of the map.
Uh...
come on.
Sorry about this.
Okay, there we go.
And I cleverly also
loaded this thing already
in Firefox.
And now if the connection
here didn't die...
See? See, the network moves--
the map moves in the back.
How cool is that?
[applause]
Yes. Should I switch off
the wireless?
[woman speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: Oh, off.
woman: Yes.
Osinga:
Oh, yeah, I can do that.
Maybe then I don't have
a connection at all, of course.
[tittering]
Okay, switching off
the thing now.
All Wave radios are off...
ready for takeoff.
Okay, so...
this is, of course, only using
the state bit of the API.
We also have
the participant API,
so this looks like
a lot of code.
If you add this bit of the code
to the same--
so what I did here is
I added to the callback
to also,
if the participants change,
also call this function.
So what we do here at the top is
we go to the Wave and we ask for
all the participants.
And then we look through
the participants and...
for each of the participants,
we retrieve a key.
And we use the participant ID
as the key
so that each of the persons
on that Wave
get their own key
in the state.
So that way we make sure
that they don't interfere
with each other.
And for each of those,
we get these little string
which is called ploc here,
you know, personal location.
And this personal location,
um, I, you know,
I could have used two strings
for the X and the Y coordinates.
'Cause what we're trying
to do here is
give each person on the Wave
a little avatar that he can move
but nobody else can.
So what we do is
we fetch the current cordinat--
coordinates
from the participants,
and if we don't have one,
we put him in
somewhere in Africa.
And then we construct
a marker.
You know, it's an Earth Google
Maps marker
using the getThumbnail method
on the participant.
And we add it to the Wave.
And the other thing that we do
is we set the icon to draggable
so it can actually be moved.
Then we attach a listener
to this thing
that makes it possible
for, you know,
the current user
to drag this thing around.
We make it such that
the [indistinct] are missing
a little bit.
But if you're not
the current viewer,
then you can't move
this thing around.
So then with this bit
of participant code
added to the gadget,
we get a nice...
[humming]
the "where are you from?"
So I added this to the...
it does load faster.
So I added this thing
with our team on it.
You can see our team members.
Say hello.
Thanks.
And, you know, I asked them
to, you know,
indicate where
they're from and...
So, you know, they--
everybody can pick up
their own--
you can see here David jumping
around in the Atlantic.
So that's...
kinda nice.
So I can...
I can move my guy around
to say, okay, I'm in Japan.
So, you know,
it's just a...
a cute little thing
where you have the shared state
and you can see
how the gadget actually
gets access
to the thing.
Since I left
the move map around,
I think we can even make it
so that David moved the map.
David moved the map.
Come on.
See? No hands.
[chuckling]
Anyway...
so that's the...
the gadget bit.
Here's a bunch of
example gadgets
that we have written
and that if the source code
is not on the Google.com site,
then it should be
really soon.
Here's the chess gadgets
that has...
was shown in the demo
which nicely shows off--
That's a good point
to make, actually.
All these gadgets,
they share the state--
they save the state
in the Wave.
But by doing that they,
you know,
they obviously get to play
in the whole...
synchronization
of the state,
so they don't have
to take care of that.
But the other thing
that they do
is since we record
all the change through the Wave,
you can automatically
just replay the thing.
So I can just go
to any of those...
waves that we have,
for example, this thing here,
and I can put it
in playback mode.
And, you know, you can see...
I can just...
where everybody moved the map
and when
and, you know, how.
So that way, you get
this powerful playback thing
and especially for games,
it's really neat
because you can play a game
and then when you're done,
you can just replay
and see where you went wrong.
So that's, you know,
kind of cool,
and you get it for free.
Uh, sudoku was also
mentioned here.
This is another--
here in the corner,
it's probably hard to read,
but it's another
cute little game
where it's based
on this magnetic poetry thing.
So you have a whole
bunch of words
and you can just
drag them around.
And if you add
a whole group of people,
you can sort of collectively
create poems.
It's, you know,
hours of fun
for people
with nothing else to do.
[laughter]
People that do have
a lot to do here
wrote this gadget
here in the corner
which is, you know,
we had one of those
late-night sessions
and then at some point,
always the point appears.
This is on the weekend and...
apparently, there's no food
at Google in the weekend.
So somebody, you know,
somebody will get hungry
and somebody else
will get hungry
and usually
the most hungry person
then finally decides
to get food for everybody.
And it's always hard
to figure out what to get.
So somebody wrote
a little gadget
that allows everybody
to add one line to the gadget
from a bunch of menus
that he screen scraped
from a bunch of websites
of restaurants that
we could do the food run to.
And so you can have this
whole discussion about the food
and the top of this Wave
then automatically
keeps track of a list of all
the things that we want to get
and from which restaurants,
so it's very neat.
Okay. So...
we get to the robot bit.
One of the reasons that robots
are cooler than gadgets
is that it just sounds
much cooler.
[laughter]
I mean, building a robot...
who can say that,
that you do that for a job?
Well, I can.
Um, so robot sits sort of
on the other side of the thing.
Here we have Carl's client,
in this case,
and Carl's also looking
at a gadget here still,
and this is the...
this is the XML documents
that is kept by its client.
And it's kept in sync
by the Wave Server.
But the Wave Server
talks not just to clients.
It also talks to a bunch
of agents that we have here.
So Spelly and Linky
are sort of the robot agents
that come with the system,
and they are on all waves
and they have another,
you know,
they sort of have
direct access to everything.
For these basic agents,
you really need that.
So they're a little special.
But in order to make it
as simple as possible
for everybody to build robots,
we have also created
a robot proxy here.
The robot proxy
also talks to the Wave Server
and it talks
to the Wave protocol.
What it does,
it takes the Wave protocol
and it converts it
to HTTP calls.
And we have
a adjacent format
where we take
those HTTP calls.
We take basically
all operations
that come from
the Wave Server
that are interesting
for your robot
and call out
to this HTTP server
that is implementing
the robot interface
with adjacent string
encoding those operations.
And then, uh, that robot
returns the thing back.
So this is essentially
the API that we have.
We have a bunch of events.
These are the things that,
as a robot, you can react to.
And we have
a bunch of operations
which are the things that,
as a robot,
you can return to us
and, uh, to modify.
Oh, one remark is
you can see here at the bottom
that it calls out
to App Engine,
and you might think
that's just Google propaganda.
But for now,
we have restricted it
to robots only
running in App Engine.
There's a bunch of good
technical reasons for
but as we progress,
we'll lift that restriction
and make it possible to run
robots in any old server
that you might have.
So the...
robots have a model of the Wave,
and robots have access
to the entire Wave,
not like gadgets
that only have access
to the little bit
that they control.
And the model is fairly similar
to the model I described before,
except for that we have
simplified it a little bit
so we--robots see, by default,
only the text in a Wave.
It makes it a lot easier
to manipulate.
And we sort of extract little
text bits from the XML document
and create a TextView
out of that,
and then if you modify
that TextView,
we figure out what bits
you modified
and throw it into
the whole OT stack
and make sure that
it synchronizes nicely.
And we have similar views
of these documents
if you want to talk
to a gadget in the Wave
or if you want to talk
to the forum.
In terms of events...
you can react to events
on three different levels.
You can react on wavelets
where, you know,
you can look whether
there's a blip created,
participant changed,
or a title changed.
And for the blips you can,
you know,
essentially see what changed
in a specific blips
or document
inside of a wavelet.
And then we have right now
only one method for the forms--
that is when a button
get clicked.
So you can insert
an entire form in a Wave,
but then when, you know,
a button gets clicked,
you can react
and do something.
Now, what can you do,
you might wonder.
A whole bunch of things.
Essentially, we allow you
to manipulate the robot
in...[stammering]
manipulate the document
in whatever way you want
by creating new replies,
creating new waves
or changing the text title
or whatever is in there.
And again,
we have this gadget form
and TextView
that makes it simple
to make text modifications
or just modify
the state of the gadget
or to modify the form.
As of today, we have
on the code, the Google site,
we have two APIs published,
one in Python
and one in Java.
And they both run on the--
and the reason that
we have done it this way
is that we have
this wire protocol
that goes out
to the HTTP servers
and that the adjacent
saying, well, we're...
we're, unfortunately,
not quite ready
to commit to that completely.
'Cause we changed
a lot of things.
So instead, we have chosen
for now to give you
the Python Library
and the Java Library,
and we can kind of promise
that we keep those APIs
fairly stable,
and the wire protocol
underneath it might change.
Once we get to the point where
we actually are fairly sure,
you know, when we get that,
we'll standardize on that.
We'll publish the thing
and, you know,
if you wanna go wild
and create other libraries,
then it's all fine.
Or if you find that,
you know,
our libraries
that will open source
or are...
are faulty or need things,
please send us the changes.
You know,
it can always be better.
Anyway, so I have here
the code in Python
of a very simple robot.
You know, I could have
taken the Java version of this,
but then, you know,
I would have needed
seven files
instead of, uh, 20 lines.
[laughter]
[applause]
Good thing
it's not JavaOne here.
Anyway, so this--
this robot is very simple.
We create here the robot.
We call it Yasr.
And you might wonder why
Yasr.
Well, that's because
when people get the chance
to play with a robot API,
there's always two things
they want to try:
One is Echoy, which echoes
whatever the user types.
And the other one
is they realize
that a Wave doesn't have
any Smiley support.
If you type a Smiley,
it doesn't stop to do that.
So they come
to the brilliant idea
that they should be
the first person to do that.
They're not.
[laughter]
So Yasr means
"yet another Smiley robot."
Okay, so Yasr subscribes
to the events
blip submitted...event.
And then it will actually
call this on blip submitted
function, which is defined here.
This thing then goes
to the context.
So we have two elements here.
We have properties and context.
Properties is...
it's a little...
so properties
is specific to that event,
and contacts is sort of
like what happened--
what is the context
in which this event happened.
So what are the bits
of the Wave?
And we...
don't quite support yet...
a good way to specify
which contacts you want.
But the idea is that as,
you know,
that you don't always want to
have full access to everything.
That, you know,
you don't want to have always
the entire Wave sent
to your poor little robot
if you're only interested
in the title changing.
Anyway, so if we have
this little thing,
we look for this string
and we look for that string
and then we substitute it
by the Unicode character
that is that thing.
So now we'll see whether...
the gods of the network are...
Here we have the Smiley robot,
and I can reply to this
and I can say...Hello.
And now...
you see, it substituted
for a tiny Smiley.
You know, that's the drawback
of using the Unicode trick.
You could also insert an image,
but then the whole code
would be a little longer.
So that's the simplest robot
that you can imagine.
It's not very useful.
Now, if we take the code
of just before
and we insert this...
we get a slightly more...
more interesting thing.
This was based on an idea of
somebody from the search team.
Essentially what it does here,
it looks at the contents
of your blip.
It looks for three
question marks
and then it substitutes it
for a star,
and it does using the Ajax
Search APIs that Google has.
It does a search for that thing.
And it looks at all the results,
and it finds back
all the things that are
using as a tiny
regular expression here
that are in bold,
and then it counts
all the things that are in bold
and it returns the one
that has the highest frequency.
So what does it all mean?
I, you know,
I'll show you what it means
by bringing up this robot.
Ah...where is he?
There we go.
So I can ask this robot
questions
by saying things like
the capital of Germany is--
It's a little scary.
I've never tried this.
So what it will do,
it will do a quick Google search
for this string,
except for it takes
the three question marks,
replace it by a star
and then essentially
try to count
what is the most likely,
you know,
answer that appears in star
in the Google search results
highlighted.
So then...
yes?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: A log?
Oh, well, it runs on App Engine,
so...
so, yes, I mean, you can
just look at...
what the App Engine thing
gets called.
I'm more concerned
that this didn't actually work.
[laughter]
Ah, there he goes!
[applause]
I mean, it's kind of nice,
because it also does things
where, you know, you don't
know in the middle
what it was like.
You can say thing like
found at Google.
'Cause you know,
there was this guy,
but I forgot his name.
Come on.
Do it.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: Well, I know!
[laughter]
Ah...poor network.
Anyway, um...
it's really quite nice,
what you can do
with just
a simple bits of Python codes.
So...we have a bunch
of other examples here
that mostly figured
in a demo this morning.
We have Polly.
It handles the flow of polling.
And it really stretches
what you can do with the API.
Again, it will--
this one is written in Java,
and you should be able
to look at the code
as of today.
It stores the...
you know, it uses the forms
to interact with the user,
and the other thing that's
kind of interesting is that
it stores the entire state
of all the thing that happens
in the Wave.
We have this little thing
called data documents,
and data documents
are like blips
except for that they're
not visible to the user.
They're really for robots
to store their state in that.
And a robot could, you know,
either use that
to share that information
with other robots,
or it can even go as far as
creating a private reply
or creating a private wavelet
with the data documents and that
so that you now have this Wave
where there's
this little bit of data
where you can store your own
arbitrary key value pairs
and that you know that
only your robot has access to.
I imagine you wanna write
something like a poker game
that, you know...
and if you want to just
play it for fun, that's fine.
But if you want to do it
more seriously,
it becomes kind of important.
You can't actually just,
you know,
look at what goes over the wire
and see that, you know,
the gadget that handles
the while poker game
actually knows what the cards
of your opponents are.
So using this day thing,
you can actually
get around that.
Bloggy publishes waves
to a blog.
So the way that that works
is that...
there are two things
that you need to do to publish.
One is you want to make this
Wave accessible to everybody,
not just the people
that are on the Wave.
'Cause by default,
waves are only accessible
by people that were added
to this Wave.
So we have come up with
this secret group--
It's called pubic@gwave.com--
which actually has
all Wave users in it.
So if you add that thing
to a Wave,
this Wave now becomes
available to everybody.
And, uh...
the nice thing about that
is that, you know,
then you can actually
use it for blogging.
Right now, if you do that,
it won't actually work
completely
because we're still, you know,
only in sandbox,
so anybody that doesn't
have a sandbox account
that goes to your blog
demonstration
will actually see some sort
of screen saying like,
look, this is a demo.
But after we go public,
we'll make it possible
that people that don't have
a Wave account
when they go
to your published Wave
get automatically signed in
by a virtual user
called anonymous
and then can interact
in a limited way
with your Wave
without having a Wave account.
Uh, Buggy.
Yeah, so Buggy is a...
the drawback
is that we're secretly
using an API
that, you know,
isn't quite ready out there.
So we can't really come out
with the code there.
But we think it demonstrates
a very nice
how you can use robots
to connect Wave
to legacy systems.
Yeah, Searchy.
Searchy is the little thing
that...
if you click in the Wave client
here on top...
well, that's interesting.
Oh, here.
It actually populates
this thing here.
And it shows off
that it's a nice combination
between UI elements
and a robot.
So, you know, we could have
gone the simple way here
and done this all on the...
on the client's site
using the search APIs
that we have at Google here.
But we decided
not to go that way
because using a robot,
we can make it so that
we can search together
And, you know, we haven't quite
worked that out to the bottom,
'cause, you know,
there's a lot to do.
But we think it's very powerful
and it's possible for,
you know, if you can't
find somebody else--
if you can't find something
on Google
or your favorite search engine
that you can just add
somebody to your search session
and that way,
search together.
Tweety, one of our, I think,
most attractive robots.
At this point,
it shows two things off.
It shows how you can sync
between
an external communication
system like Twitter and Wave,
but it also shows you--
and this is in the details
of the API--
but you can...
so by default,
everything that the robot does
is assigned to that robot.
And in the case of Twitter,
you don't actually want that,
because you don't want
the post from Twitter coming in
being labeled as from
Twitter the robot.
You want to have this post
coming in
being labeled from...
the person
that Twittered this.
So we have this thing
where robots
can create blips on account
of external people.
And that opens up
an entire new way,
an entire new gateway
to building robots,
because that way you can
build gateway robots.
You could do this for email,
for example,
where you take incoming emails
and you make them appear
on account of somebody else.
Okay...
I wanted to leave a lot of
time for questions.
I see we have
16 minutes left, so...
I'll just see what
we can do.
Well, it should be okay.
Yes.
So the last bit of the API
is the extension API.
And, uh, the extension API
is our answer
to how do you distribute
these robots and these gadgets?
Because, you know, we could
stick them into a gallery.
That is sort of like
the standard practice
in the industry.
And then your users,
every time they want
to invoke this robot
or every time they want
to insert this gadget,
they will have to go
to this gallery
and find that thing back.
And, you know,
it's a lot of hassle.
Especially since, you know,
that works kind of okay
for something like iGoogle,
because there you installed
the gadget once,
and you're done.
But here,
if you like this chess gadget,
more likely than not,
you'll want to keep inserting
this chess gadget
and play chess with many,
many of your...
of your friends.
So then if--
every time you have to go there,
it's a lot of hassle.
So instead we came up with idea
of these extensions,
and extensions is essentially
a little...
it's a little XML document
that hooks...
that...connects
a hook to an action.
So we have a bunch of hooks
in the client,
and right now I think
we only have two
in the new Wave menu,
and in the toolbar
you can add things.
But we're actively
working to expand this
to make it possible
to hook into keyboard shortcuts
and the file menu,
and we have plans
to support text macros,
and that sort of thing.
And all these things
will then invoke
one of the...
the things that we have.
What can they do?
Essentially,
they can trigger an action,
and the actions
that they can do right now
is they can insert a gadget
in the current Wave,
they can add a participant,
or they can create a new Wave.
And again, there, you know,
there's an infinite amount
of new actions
you'd come up with,
and we expect to add them.
So how does it look
in practice?
So this is the...
the document
that I was talking about.
In this case we say, well,
we have this extension
insert something
into the toolbar.
And there's a little info
thing here
with a tool tip
and an icon.
And this is an icon that,
unfortunately for you guys,
I drew, so...
it's not as pretty,
half as pretty
as the rest of the client.
This is one of the things
that always breaks Lars' heart
when it comes to developers
that...
they have the ability
to make things ugly.
[laughter]
So please,
if you publish something,
make sure it looks pretty
so Lars is also happy.
And then we have
this other thing
where we insert
this participant map
that, you know,
we had before.
Oh!
So then if we...
right now...
the way that you create
these things
are a little unfortunate
because we haven't...
We'll come up with
a better UI for that.
But this
is for developers only,
so we figured that
it's probably okay.
So the way it works
is you go to
the debug menu here,
which also...and you choose
this add extension installer
where you insert
the manifest URL and...
image URL that shows
the content of the thing.
And you get something
like this.
And you can see here that...
that, you know, you have
this little puzzle piece
that describes the extension
that I created.
And now if I create
this install button--
let me show you...look.
There is no ugly
toolbar button here.
But now when I click install,
nothing happens.
Let's see...
Wireless network unavailable.
Well, I thought
I didn't have...
Yes, so now it switched
from install to uninstall
because I haven't installed
this thing.
And now if I go to the--
ooh.
[laughter]
To the edit button, you see
here, indeed, an ugly button.
How nicely created.
And I can go ahead
and create a new Wave,
and now I can insert
this gadget,
and you see that, you know,
it inserted that
"where are you" gadget
with my draggable icon here.
So that's a really neat way
to distribute applications
that you built on top of Wave.
So, I mean, you can create
a Wave with that installer on it
and then invite
all your friends,
an they can invite
their friends.
Or you can create this Wave,
describe the application
that you built,
and embed that thing
on the website.
So you can have your website
with your product.
And people clicking
that button--
well, when they visit your
website, they see immediately
whether they have that extension
installed or not.
And people clicking that button
will get that extension
installed in their client.
So it's a really neat way
to combine the...
the install niceties
of traditional software
with the greatness
of these sort of
web-based applications.
Okay, thanks.
That was all I have.
So we have like ten minutes
for questions.
And again, haveasec.com/io
will take your feedback
for this thing.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
If you do have a question,
please use the microphone
so...
this talk is being recorded,
and it'd be nice
for the people
that want
to listen to it later.
Uh, yes.
man: On the android platform,
we can run a Wave client
within a browser frame.
Is it possible--
will it be possible
to have in the Android API
the ability to access wavelets
and these blips directly?
Without having to create
a separate frame.
Osinga: Um, so...
you want to...
man: Could we create
our own Wave client
using, in essence,
the Android API
instead of having to go
through a browser within--
a browser frame within
the Android API?
Osinga: Uh...
well, I suppose you could,
but it seems that--
So that sort of--
so the API
that I described here
is really about
how you expand the...
the Wave client as we build it
and using your robots.
If you want to do something
like that
and build a native client
for Wave,
that will be possible,
but it's not covered
with our current APIs.
'Cause for that,
we would have to...
you know,
and we're working on that.
The protocol that is spoken
between the server
and the client
would have to be stable enough
for us to publish it
so that you can come up
with your own native client.
man: Yes.
Osinga: You can do it
kind of using federation.
I mean, if you went
to the talk this morning,
there was this Python client
with text-based form stuff.
man: Yes.
Osinga: So that's kind of
in that direction.
man: Okay. Thank you.
Osinga: Thanks.
Take from the other side.
Sorry.
man: Yeah, hi.
Thanks for the great talk.
So far I've only seen you guys
logging in
with consumer Google Accounts,
Gmail Accounts.
Are there any plans to make
this work with Google Apps,
specifically premier edition,
and enable things like
signed fetch
for secure data connector
and private gadgets
and these kinds of things?
Osinga: Well,
there's lots of plans.
To start with
your first question,
so actually, the...
this thing is not a...
this thing here runs
on a hosted domain, right?
So it's not your normal
Gmail Account.
It's a separate thing,
so we have...
that is how we'll start,
with just domains
for your thing, and...
yeah, so the embedding story,
if you wanna continue that,
will at some point support...
the ability for, you know,
for non-Google people
to log into there.
But we're not quite done there.
But, yeah, we're working
on that.
And, yeah, this whole...
gadgets--
we're also working on that,
yeah.
man: Great. That's good news.
Thank you.
Osinga: So...yes and yes.
Yeah.
man: I had a couple questions.
Osinga: A couple?
man: One, is there any
SEO combinations,
like if we wanted to use this
as sort of like
a...open discussion
for maybe a particular user
or instance of something
on a site,
to have that be, you know,
SEOed at all?
I know it's active,
it's constantly changing,
but...is that possible?
'Cause I know it's a frame,
and I don't know,
it's not gonna be a next
in relation to the site at all.
Osinga: Yeah.
Yeah, so...again.
I mean, this is all
a developer preview,
so a lot of these questions,
we have answers,
but we're not quite ready
with them.
So we have a...
The way it will work is that
any of those waves
also has a static version.
And we'll make it so that
if you do the right thing
with the embed,
that we'll have some sort
of information
to point out to the crawler
where to find the static
version of that thing.
Now, of course, the crawler
won't, you know--
it will get the static version
and not the dynamic version.
But we think we can
make it so that
that will all work out
and that the crawler will index
the content on your website
as belonging to you at the point
of where it came by.
man: Okay, and then
one quick one.
Script libs, like dojo
or new tools or something--
can I use those in extensions
without, you know,
before I use new tools
and erect a dom
with the dollar sign?
Is that possible?
Osinga: Where?
man: Like using a script lib
library inside of the extensions
to do...you know,
if I wanted to augment
certain things with...
Osinga: So...you can totally
use something, you know...
I'm still not sure
I follow--
man: Okay, so like new tools,
if I use that,
if I instantiate it, obviously,
if there's any other--
It's done with web toolkits,
so I'm sure it spits out
native script.
But it's obviously gonna
collide and destroy
any other library out there
that's trying to...
Osinga: So...
so the gadgets...
the gadgets run
normal JavaScript.
We have a grid library
that lets you build
Wave specific gadgets
for using grid.
We don't have any dojo
or...that--
man: Oh, I was just asking
if I could use them.
Is that okay,
since it's all native script,
it's gonna be
inside that frame?
It's not gonna like
hurt it or anything or...
you guys are cool with that?
Osinga: No, no, no, no.
And, you know,
I like JQuery,
so, you know, for some
of these things I use JQuery.
Um...yeah.
man: What browser
would Wave run on?
Osinga: So currently,
it runs in
what we like to call
modern browsers.
So that's like...
[laughter]
But once we're launched,
we'll support Internet Explorer,
Safari, Chrome, and Firefox.
[indistinct]
man: Can you talk
a little bit about
the maybe interoperative
ability
between setting up non-Google
Accounts related to Wave,
so if we set up
our own server
that has the federation
protocol implemented
and then we need to be able
to communicate with waves,
I assume you won't have to
log into a Google Account
in order to communicate
with waves.
And will those be able
to be integrated?
Does that make sense?
Osinga: Yeah.
So...right now, you do have to.
So right now the only way
to use Wave
is if you have
a Wave Sandbox Account.
man: Right.
Osinga: But...
we expect that we can get--
So the first step
for this will be
that we'll have
this anonymous API that lets...
lets you embed a Wave
on a website
and then assign a user
to the user that comes in there
using your own
sort of thing.
And this will be
very untrusted,
but it allows them
at least to...
have Wave-like discussions
on that website.
But we expect that
we'll come out with an API
that will actually
allow you to do that
with any...any system...
you know, like...
any open ID like thing.
Does that make sense?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: Well, so, yeah.
If you go to Federation Wave,
of course, anything is possible.
Right? Then...
Yeah. Let's take one
from this side again.
man: With regard
to the embedding thing,
it uses just an ID
that identifies
a particular Wave, right?
Osinga: Yes.
man: So if you put in
a different ID,
you'd get a different Wave,
obviously.
Osinga: Yes.
man: Is there any sort of
security concerns
where, you know,
if you went in and changed--
someone went into the source
and changed, you know...
Osinga: Well, there's always
security concerns.
So the way it works
is that...
if you put an ID in there
that the user
that visits your page
has to have access rights
to that Wave,
otherwise they will see
a warning that they don't.
man: Okay.
Osinga: And you can add
this special user public
to the Wave
to make sure that everybody
has access to that Wave.
But of course,
that will result
to the thing that everybody
has access to this Wave.
That's why in a normal
Wave client if you do that,
you see a little banner
on top warning you
that this Wave is actually
accessible for everybody.
And we have this publish API
that lets the robot
that adds public to the Wave
also set the little
data document in that Wave
specifying
where it's published,
which will change this banner
from a generic warning
saying "this Wave
is publicly accessible"
to "this Wave
has been published
by the publishing author
at the URL."
That's what you saw
at the demo this morning.
woman: So the content
of the Wave
seems to be text right now.
I was wondering how flexible
the content model is.
Could you have more structured
types of data
that you can collaboratively
edit?
Osinga: Well, so the...
the waves are...
are not text only.
I mean, so a Wave
is a tree of blips, right?
And these blips each
are XML documents
with arbitrary structure
in them.
The thing that we have
decided right now
is that robots--and there's
good reasons for this--
for right now, robots see
these blips as strings of text.
It just makes the robots
a lot easier to develop.
But we expect that over time
we'll add different views
of this text for the robots
that will allow you to do
more of these arbitrary things.
And the same for gadgets.
So right now, the gadget
state is a key list--
a list of key value pairs.
But over time,
we expect to make this into
more data structures
that get you whatever
structure that you want.
man: Any plans for old-school
mail protocol integrability,
SMTP, IMAP?
Osinga: Oh. Yes.
man: Can you elaborate?
Osinga: But partly,
we hope that
we'll get our API
to the point
where it's not us that build
a mail gateway
but where anybody can come up
with their own gateway.
So if you look at--I think
the Twitter demo that we have
gives a glimpse of that.
Of course, Titter is,
you know, very simple.
man: So no plans for you guys
to provide those
out of the gate.
You want us to kind
of come in--
Osinga: Well, that would
be ideal, you know, just...
[laughter]
That would save so much work.
So that's part of why
we have this API,
'cause, you know, it...
there's...
and, you know, I think
that sort of thing,
when you get here--
there's loads and loads
of ideas
and things that are possible
with Wave,
and we can't all do them.
man: You want to displace
email, though,
like the keynote
was pointing at.
You're probably gonna want
to interoperate with it
from the get-go a little bit.
Osinga: Yes. No, no, no.
And I think...
I think that, of course,
that is one of the things
that we'll have at some point.
That's a really short answer.
I just wanted to...
Okay, I see there's
ten seconds on the clock.
man: What would Wave address
look like?
Osinga: So a Wave address
right now
looks like the domain
that hosts that address,
and then there's a bunch of
seemingly random characters.
To show you,
you can get to the Wave...
Oh, what do you mean,
the Wave address?
man: Like if you want to
replace email,
you're gonna have to put
something on your business card.
What's that gonna look like?
Osinga: Oh, so right now,
we just use Google Accounts
to log in and to communicate.
I thought you were
talking about--
so for embedding,
you need just Wave ID
which you can get
from the debug menu here.
I thought I showed it quickly,
because some may want
to try with that.
man: I mean more like
if I ran my own Wave Server,
and I wanted people
to be able to email me where
what would that look like?
Would it look like
an email address?
Would you guys have
the equivalent of MX records
in the NS for waves?
Osinga: Yes.
Yeah. So yeah,
it looks like an email address.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Osinga: So yeah.
It looks like an email address
or that the convention is,
you know,
it's user at...at a domain,
right?
So you reach that user
using a protocol
at that domain,
and the default is email
in a lot of people's heads,
but we use the same convention.
I think that's all we have
time for today.
If you have more questions
and you can find me,
ask them.
[woman speaking indistinctly]
[applause]
I mentioned it twice.